hey dr. Berg here we have one more week
to sign up for the seminar we're doing
October 3rd in Northern Virginia I would
like to personally invite you to come to
the seminar if you can a lot of people
are flying out from all over the country
and it's going to be an incredible event
we're going to teach you step by step
very simply how to do acupressure for
your body type and that includes the
thyroid the adrenal the ovary the
pancreas and for hot flashes and
menstrual stuff so one of the reasons
why I want to do this is I want to
capture a lot of demonstrate
demonstrations on all of you
so we're going to be bringing people up
every single person up and I'm going to
work on them in front of the camera so
we can record that so you can learn from
that so the body types and acupressure
for pain not just regular pain but
chronic pain and systemic pain which is
pain all over you're going to learn
about referred pain and how to identify
what causes what it's a great technique
and it's a lot of fun to help your
friends and you and yourself also body
symmetry this is a new thing that I came
up with to make someone majorly
symmetrical front and back side to side
if you take an average person and you
evaluate them they are completely
crooked they're tight on one side of
their body and they're loose on the
other their posture is bad so we're
going to show you how to make yourself
very symmetrical it's going to help
sleep it's going to help you exercise
without wearing at a joint helps pain
and you'll love it and part of that is
getting rid of old injuries which you're
going to love that too
acupressure for your body stress I want
to show you some new things on how to
extract a tremendous amount of stress in
a very short period of time to put a
person in the most wonderful delta-wave
sleep that they've ever had so I want to
invite you come out to the seminar more
information click below and I hope to
see you there personally